[Music]
you
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me live from the City
Winery
my name is Joshua fields Melbourne and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists live in Nashville come
on Nashville you can do better than that
I said we are live in Nashville that was
much better thank you so much for being
here we want this this place is amazing
so next time we'll have to do like two
nights cuz you all sold this out like
months and events so thank you so much
for being here we've got some folks with
some questions and Ryan you have any
answers I've got I've got a few answers
I hope one of them works
I got borrow one sure honey what's your
name where you from hey there I'm
tishanna I'm from Kansas City represent
okay the Missouri side okay there is a
difference anyway I appreciate your
presence and appreciate your message
I've been to come decluttering a lot and
my husband is here he was drugged with
me there should be a drugged at the bug
too so we have three kids and we're
working on decluttering them as well so
working on that hey I found something
that kinda sorta works with them I just
kind of packed up a bunch of their toys
and a bin and kept it in the garage for
a month and nobody noticed any of that
stuff was gone so then it went to
Goodwill so I know anyway but my
question is really more about work
sometimes you guys talk about mental
clutter and so I work as a nurse and
kind of everything I feel like falls to
the nurse like oh ask the nurse the
doctors not going to deal with this the
scheduling person doesn't want to deal
with it the you know person up front
they're like oh the nurse asked the
nurse s iners so it's just this barrage
of I do have decision fatigue just from
you know all this stuff
and I feel like it's hard for me to let
that go and decompress and then when I
go home and with my kids and my husband
it's hard to be present because I'm
still cluttered in my mind with all the
works sure it bleeds over into your
personal life for sure
and so you are quite often the catch-all
for everything else that either people
don't want to do can't do whatever and
here's the good so first of all thank
you for doing what you what you're doing
it's a really important job and I'm
certainly grateful for that and here's
here's what I'll say is because it is so
important that there there's a there's a
lot of weight on on your shoulders right
and so it seems to me that the the the
clutter that you're feeling internally
it's emotional clutter it's mental
clutter it's it's everything that's
going on inside and what I've realized
is what you're what you're doing is
important and so the thing from for me
it took me a long time to realize this
like in fact I'll tell you like it
wasn't until maybe this year while we
were out in the road and I really felt
like wow this is I mean I don't believe
like and what you you're born to do one
thing for the rest of your life or you
were bought you know you're
predetermined to be an astronaut or a
yoga teacher or a writer yeah I was
really born for this but I really felt
like wow this is what I'm supposed to be
doing right now like this is one of the
most important things I could be doing
with my time and you're doing that right
now and the thing that that I think will
help you is accepting that you actually
do have the answers that's why people
are coming to you it's not just so they
can pon work off on you it's because
they they I mean maybe it is sometimes
but but really they they need to lean on
you for your expertise and your ability
to to do what other people can't do and
so people are there because they need
your help whether it's patients or
doctors or administration they all need
your help and that's a lot of
responsibility and and and the good news
is that's a good thing because the
opposite of having none of that
responsibility means you're probably not
doing something nearly as meaningful
have you heard of the 20/20 rule I'm
kidding so my answer it's one of the
three answers I brought No
first off thank you so much for coming
here to support us it means so much to
us to everyone here so yes thank you for
that what I'll say is one thing that
Josh said that really stuck out to me is
the weight on your shoulders and a lot
of times we find ourselves in life where
we do have a ton of weight on our
shoulders and often I have to remind
myself when I start to feel that weight
I've got to remind myself that some of
that stuff that's on my shoulders I can
take off and any Boulder that I've
picked up I am able to to take off some
of that your kids you can't really put
those boulders down or I wouldn't
recommend it at least but what I'll say
is is when I'm thinking about your
situation my first thought is like what
borders do you have that you've picked
up that you can absolutely set down and
sometimes that means letting down some
friends and family but the good news is
is that your friends and family they
love you and they want you to be happy
and the ones that truly do love you and
want you to be happy they will support
you and it's okay if you tell them no a
little bit more often sure um the other
thing I was thinking about too is how do
you approach this because it's you know
it's work that's stressing you out you
can't just quit your job and you've got
your other weight on your shoulders when
you come home and you you can't get rid
of your family so the question that I'm
asking myself is like where is where is
there somewhere in your day that can
give so with your family maybe it does
it seems like you've a very supportive
husband by the way the fact that yeah he
let you drag him out here so that right
now right there you have more than what
most people don't have which is a
supportive partner so that alone is is a
huge leg up the other thing I'll say too
is that as you support a partner he
wants you to unwind so is there
something in the daily routine that that
you guys can talk about to maybe help
you unwind a little bit more I don't
know if you meditate or just going on a
walk to decompress
I mean there
those are two things I definitely do
when I am feeling overwhelmed within the
well on that same topic you see was kind
of talk about these interstitial zones
sometimes I remember when I worked in
the corporate world I'm an introvert and
so I don't know if you're introvert or
extrovert somewhere in between but my
job was very extroverted like 16 hours a
day extroverted and it was weird I
didn't realize this until very recently
I was back in Dayton Ohio driving around
one of the routes that I would drive
because I've managed a bunch of these
retail stores which is really ironic the
whole minimalism thing and I was driving
on the same road that I drove a million
times going between these different
stores and I realized like I felt at
peace in my car like commuting why does
this feel so good because it was one of
the only times throughout my entire 16
hour work days that I was by myself
that was my decompression zone and so
maybe for you you also have a
decompression zone and it may may mean
you may or may not have one on your
commute or maybe the commute isn't a
long enough decompression zone but then
then it maybe there's some other
interstitial zone that you can still
decompress in I mean even today well
we're on the road and our partners are
with those Becks was with me we were
walking around all all downtown today
and then afterward I'm like I got to
take a nap before we go like do this I
just need spend some time and we're back
in in the hotel room and like she's
there just talking talking talking then
she looks at me because she's
understanding and she goes you want me
to leave you the [ __ ] alone right now
don't you
I'm like well I just want to go to sleep
so unless you want to go to sleep and I
think part of that is is is refining our
communication with each other so we can
have a sort of fun moment instead of me
saying hey leave me alone it's also
realizing being more aware of of what's
going on around us and asking the people
who were with us to be to be more aware
as well to help out and sometimes it's
even with lla that's like I can tell I
just wants to go you know the gym or
something hey let me grab Ella for a
couple hours and you go do whatever you
need to do and ll ask me like what why
why are we going to the coffee shop or
whatever
because your mom needs some alone time
and I think if we can all help give each
other what we need we'll all be better
off because of it
yeah the other thing I was gonna say is
the other factor is your job right I
remember
when Josh and I were in the corporate
world and I started to see those changes
in him like one of the one of the
changes I remember very clearly was is
he set expectations with our boss that
he wasn't going to answer the phone
after a certain time and he wasn't going
to you know answer the phone or return
emails before a certain time so he gave
them a window the funny story is he was
out to dinner with a friend Christmas
Eve and it's like 6 o'clock at night the
retail stores are about to close at 8
p.m. so josh is out with his friend our
boss calls him Josh ignores it he calls
back Josh ignores it he calls again and
finally you know Josh picks up the phone
hey what can I do for you he's like hey
man what what was what is going on with
you I I need I need your sales numbers
right now what where are your stores at
and Josh was like I don't know the
answer to that the stores are closing in
two hours you're gonna have that report
in two hours I don't have that answer
I'm sorry and he goes well that's
ridiculous my boss he wants the numbers
I need the numbers right now and Josh
said well you need to tell your boss
that that's an unreasonable expectation
now the only reason why Josh could get
away with anything like that and he was
very respectful I mean it wasn't
patronizing it was a very professional
call it's because josh added a ton of
value to the company so for you or
anyone else out there if you know that
you are adding a ton of value for your
company and and you know who you are you
have leverage in that leverage it's not
to say hey I want to work part-time and
I want you to double my pay right that's
silly but there are things there are
reasonable things that you can ask
or that if you're adding value your boss
their boss will go way out of their way
to support you and to keep you on on
staff so I don't think there's like one
just sound like meditation is this Magic
Bullet answer that's gonna fix
everything but I think if you can kind
of look at both parts and you know kind
of pick and choose a few things with the
support of a great partner yeah I think
you could totally take you know get that
metal mental under Petzl mental clutter
say that five times fast
you can definitely declutter that mental
clutter a little bit more than what
you're doing now thank you for your help
thank you howdy
what's your name the house tonight so
often on to my question and I am so glad
you're female your ladies are here today
because this question is probably better
answered by them when it comes to don't
worry I'll answer for them like I always
do but when it comes to makeup and hair
products and all of those things
especially as a single woman you know I
like to put my best foot forward and
look my best
how can I make mindful decisions and
minimize you know my consumption when it
comes to those kind of product cosmetics
in general yeah so what are you
struggling with like I want to make
mindful decisions I want to buy products
that are ecologically friendly you know
I don't want to have a bunch of things
that I'm not using that you know society
tells us that we need yeah yeah yeah
that's the interesting thing because I
saw back tonight when she was like
putting some mascara on and she wears
very little makeup and I fully support
her whenever she wants to where she
could put a clown nose on
she could borrow mine I wear it
sometimes around the house and I fully
support her but yeah I think she's
totally beautiful without a drop of
makeup on her face whatsoever it's like
that Macklemore line like the greatest
live or sold is the women look better
and makeup and and I mean I feel that
way and like it it's it seems
superfluous to me but that's just my
personal opinion and I also realized
that that people have certain
preferences and so I support her and
whatever whatever her preferences are
she doesn't wear a whole lot of makeup
but if you wanted to I okay what we do
whatever you want to do whatever you
find value what brings you joy and I'm
not going to judge that here's the thing
that you have to realize most of that
pressure that you feel that societal
pressure is internal pressure and and we
think other people give a [ __ ] about
what we're wearing but they don't care
at all
Ryan wears a black shirt and jeans every
day and I mean people are rarely gonna
come up to him hey man why you wearing a
black shirt today and the truth is like
people don't really care and if and when
they in the rare instances where they do
care they it says a whole lot more about
them than it does about you we had a
friend her name's Nina she lives in
Chicago and she was a a HR manager for a
large pharmaceutical company and she did
this experiment for I think it was a
year she wore the same outfit for a year
and it wasn't like Ryan where it's like
that's pretty simple or whatever and we
have that stigma like what women have to
dress you know especially for the
occasion and really Standa but she wore
a bright red sweater and black pants
every day for a year and one person
commented the entire time
hey didn't you wear that earlier this
week and and what she found out is like
oh man all this pressure that I've been
putting on myself all these years the
make up the clothes the appearance I
feel the pressure and if I picked it up
then I can let it go man now I really do
want to talk about the 20/20 rule well I
mean that's the first thing that comes
to my mind when makeup or like artists
they will reach out to me a lot and what
do I do with all these art supplies I
don't know what rules are gonna work
best for you but you've got to come up
with some some kind of guidelines to
work off of
so the 20/20 rule you know Josh and I we
basically have this theory or theory or
our guess is it works like 99% of the
time it has worked 100% of the time for
both of us but the idea is anything that
you hold on to just in case artists
applies makeup anything else that you
hold on to just in case you can replace
for less than $20 in less than 20
minutes now maybe that is a rule that
doesn't work for you and that's okay but
what what rules are gonna work for you
Josh and I we talk a lot about the 9090
rule where if there's something I
haven't worn used you know done
something within the last 90 days and
I'm going through it you know the drunk
drew and I find that one USB cord extra
USB cord that came with something I'm
like yeah I've got plenty those probably
not gonna use this in the next 90 day so
then then I'll get rid of it again maybe
the 90 90 rule doesn't work for you but
maybe it's you know six months maybe
it's the 180 180 rule so you've got to
find some kind of foundation to build
off of - to help guide you through when
you're making all of these decisions the
other thing I want to say too is if you
ever are buying a product if you're ever
putting on makeup if you ever you know
consuming something just because you
think someone else is gonna like you
more for that that's probably the person
you don't want to hang out with and it's
and it's and I'm not judging that person
it's just that that sounds like it's
probably not something a friendship that
you want to foster
so I would I would really at anytime I
asked that question or I'll tell that to
myself oh if I get this one thing oh man
if I get a really dark black t-shirt
Josh will like me so much more no I
don't think about that but I'll tell you
I think about it with my car I mean I
live in we live in LA now so a lot of
nice cars driving around La in fact
Mariah and I are 2004 Toyota Corolla
that's in the garage is by far like the
crappiest car that's in the garage yeah
so you get me on this it's like I don't
have a car payment I love it and never
in a million years when I go out and
bring on more debt just so I can impress
people that I really don't care about
thank you thank you one second before we
move on here
so for those of you came early you got a
special treat can we give it up for
Griffin house it was here tonight and so
we we have something called an added
value segment we usually have at the the
end of the episode but since we're here
in Nashville and we we dragged Griffin
out here tonight he's legitimately one
of our favorite musicians I've seen him
like 20 times live like in the craziest
places like I drove the Muncie Indiana
once to watch him and so Ryan earlier
when he introduced himself was like
three dozen times and we tried to do the
math and I think we were just a few
times shy of that it's called hyperbole
yeah but if we get him to come out and
play one more time it'll be really close
to that so he doesn't all right so how
about we have Griffin house come out and
play a song for us tonight
yeah
[Applause]
he's right there wherever you want right
here would you please yeah
Griffin's gonna play it an outstanding
song from his third album that's right
it's called better than love check one
two one two
[Music]
I'm said if you're so right we will not
be singing along with this thing
[Music]
[Music]
honey when you doubt my love for you
look into my eyes what I'm going through
even if we change and fall out of you
hold my hand is better than love
save me from myself got my back when I
need her
snowell one hands and
you will always be my
[Music]
you will always be you will always be
you will always be my
[Music]
sometimes dreams they don't come true I
was scared of that when I met you but I
stayed patient I was kind
[Music]
telling you to take your time
turn my life around
[Music]
made it okay to let you down
there's no one else in the world
you will always be my girl you will
always be you always be you always be
[Music]
[Music]
so when I'm walking down the road and
I'm feeling mad cuz I can't understand
the things you do
nothing turns out the way we planned
still my baby and I'm still your bed
they say
me from myself you got my back when I
need
no one else in
you will always be my girl
[Music]
you'll always be you'll always be you
will always be my girl
ladies and gentlemen Griffin house if
it's okay with with Griffin here we'll
get him the I've just come out here and
bring a chair maybe we'll get you to
stick around for some questions sure
okay great give me a hug brother thanks
so much man all right so it's time well
what time is it Ryan oh it is time for
our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning around where well we usually
answer questions for social media but
Josh and I will not be on our phones up
here in front of you guys if it odd well
we we try to like answer regular
questions we with like these pithy
answers we call the minimal Maxim's that
Jess catalogs over at minimal Maxim's
calm they're like these really nice wrap
it up in a bow answers but we don't have
those yet and so we'll just monitor on a
bit until we get a good answer that's
tweetable and hopefully Griffin can help
us along the way Carly what's your name
hi I'm Olivia howdy I'm from I just
moved down to Nashville about a year ago
my question I sort of struggled a little
bit being mindful about food and I know
it's something that you both have talked
about at length in the podcast Ryan I
know for you it's been a little bit more
of a health thing but I was wondering if
you had any tips for sort of to be able
to like stop looking at food I was like
entertainment and more about being
mindful and conscious about it yeah I
mean so the pithy answer is food is not
entertainment but let's let's unpack
what that means right and just can you
grab Griffin's guitar so he doesn't feel
like he's gonna just start playing songs
and although you know what would be
great if like he answered every question
with he doesn't realize this is like
actually my crutch with my hands I can
make it without it okay yeah and so so
really well let's I mean we can we can
we can move this out a little bit so for
me food was a big problem I weighed 80
pounds more than I weigh now and I was
it's an addiction right and it's a
compulsion and it becomes it becomes
this weird thing where it's a reward
system for me
in two different facets it was a reward
system for me when I achieved something
oh yeah let's celebrate let's have a
shitty meal that's really bad for me and
and or it was I feel bad about myself
and I still get this impulse now when I
get overly stressed or I don't sleep
well I want to eat unhealthy stuff or
just eat in general and so we tend to
binge on things that that tastes good
we're we're willing to give up long-term
health for short-term gain when the
opposite should be true we should be
willing to give up the short-term
pleasure for for the the long-term
long-term well lived life you know for
our long-term well-being and so I mean I
think ultimately comes down to talking
about not just food foods part of it but
anything that we get addicted to it
could be social media can be drugs and
alcohol it can be food what are our
pacifiers and then and then the question
then is what are the triggers for those
pacifiers and for me it in order to
change it I had to replace the triggers
for me
I ate whenever you eat you're supposed
to eat breakfast right because it's the
most important meal of the day
which is total nonsense right I mean it
that that's a lie that we've been sold
over many generations and the truth is
that breakfast is by far the least
important meal of the day but marketers
advertisers are really good and in fact
I mean it's one of the reasons we don't
do advertisers on the podcast is is
advertisers are really good at getting
you to buy
it's either stuff you don't need or also
stuff that's just bad for you we I was
listening to Chris crecer talk about
this recently he has a new book that
just came out and I'm blanking on the
title but we've reap our society
marketers have
packaged waste products corn oil soybean
oil
this is food waste these are things are
supposed to be thrown away and now that
there they're calling it food and it's
repackaged and it's a cheaper
alternative and no it's it's literally
trash and they're selling us back our
trash and so we have to be really
cognizant about what our habits are and
then how to light how do I change those
habits what are my triggers and so for
me when it comes to health whenever I
feel feel stressed or I want to
celebrate instead of that being the
trigger for food I have to have it be a
trigger for something else so what is
your new healthier trigger and so yeah
food is not entertainment as my my pithy
answer for you but there's there's a
little bit more there for you either one
of you want to want to add in alright
I'll go if you don't have anything all
right
um I don't really have anything in there
I'm just gonna wander on um yeah sugar
is really addictive
that's my spit the answer no Mariah and
I have been going through this she just
like the last two three years has just
had some digests you know health stuff
so I've been trying to support her with
different diets for me the easiest well
the easiest way that I really got out
suggest you do this I got control over
my my food impulses was I went vegan for
a year on a bet with Josh he only lasted
11 months and he still owes me a dollar
but I'll tell ya go through that year I
totally retrained how I ate so I broke
my my diet with I remembers like this
nice big piece of cheesecake yes it was
from the Cheesecake Factory because
that's where you eat in Ohio and I
remember it like just scarfing this
thing down I was like oh this is so good
like oh my goodness
loved it and then I woke up at like 2:00
in the morning I thought I literally had
appendicitis like my stomach was hurting
so bad and it's because I had not
digested dairy and so long it's it was
it caused me a lot of pain and from
there I did not I I didn't go back to me
I was just like oh I'm not gonna see
what other stuff does to me I'm just
gonna go ahead and like incorporate you
know some fish back in so forth and so
on so like I said I don't recommend you
do anything extreme like that I think
you certainly could but the reason why I
use that example though is because for
me it was easier fast than it was to
diet is that my pet the answer yes
perfect so it's easier faster than it is
to diet so what I would I would suggest
that you do is don't don't again don't
I'm gonna be a vegan and cut everything
out that's crazy what you've got to do
is you know pick one thing that you
really want to focus on is it more
vegetables is it less sugar whatever it
is just kind of focus on one thing at a
time and I'll tell you with Mariah as an
accountability partner it really really
helps so find a friend who or a
co-worker or an enemy whoever that also
wants to change the way that they eat
and and and just start you know kind of
piecing it together one thing at a time
but to to go into it as a diet because
if you're gonna tell yourself oh well I
want to lose five pounds I'm gonna go on
a diet and great you lose five pounds
you come off the diet you're gonna gain
the five pounds back don't look at it as
a temporary diet those changes that you
make like you want to look at those as
lifestyle changes and what I'll tell you
is like after doing the ketogenic thing
after stop eating sugar like I hardly
got a little more ayah she still craves
sugar all the time but I like I hardly
ever crave it I'm just waiting
for you honey before you wake up and
you're like no I don't want to have a
doughnut she doesn't eat doughnuts by
the way but she still wants to but what
I'll say is like yeah if you incorporate
some of those good habits into your life
it will absolutely train the way that
your body feels in the way that your
brain thinks and you will actually lose
those cravings but you've got to take
some type of massive action and just
like I said start with one one thing at
a time
howdy what's your name brother hey Josh
hey Ryan thank you so much for being
here guys my name is rock I'm from
Knoxville Tennessee born and raised I
like one in Knoxville that really yeah
that's right you were that's why you
came to Knoxville when I first
discovered you guys why did that make
sense to people showed up at that
Knoxville stop so my question is less
about minimalism and more about the
business side of what you guys do after
someone that is looking to make a living
providing inspiration and knowledge like
you all do I absolutely agree that the
top priority or one of the top
priorities should be adding value like
you all talked about yeah however could
you give some more color to the
transition between the 52 person blog
that you mentioned in your speech to
making a living doing what you're doing
today Griffin we were just backstage
talking about this right beforehand like
because it's really nice to show up this
is actually our second smallest event of
the entire tour and it's great just to
and you you you come to a place like
this and it's a relatively intimate
crowd but this crowd of three or four
hundred people here tonight it would
have been by far the largest crowd on
our first second third fourth or fifth
tour that literally that first tour we
did 33 cities and when we show that
Knoxville was the fourth city we showed
up there and no one showed up it was
like this bookstore coffee shop place
and and I'm like all right well I'll
just kind of we'll just wait it out a
little bit longer a little bit longer
and then nope no one's here we we as
we're leaving we open the door walk out
the first down the two steps and this
couple walks up hey you're the
minimalists sorry relate and I'm like
yes we are the minimalists and we're
here to help and the thing I learned I I
don't look at it as like what we do
going out and inspiring people or maybe
you or even influencing well we go out
and we do it we tell stories and a lot
of those stories that we tell now
whether it's on the podcast or the live
talks that we give they started because
we went out on that
three city tour and just started talking
to people and more important we started
listening and found out what resonated
with people we tell some great stories
that I thought were great and it was
just people like what that's like I have
some sort of mixed metaphor and I
thought it was really profound and then
all of a sudden Ryan would say yeah then
after the packing party and they'd be
like what's a packing party like tell me
more about that and you start to realize
like oh this resonates this doesn't this
does this doesn't and you figure out
what does add value to other people's
lives but it it starts somewhere it
starts with one person and it didn't
it's not like we just started to blog
and all of a sudden a bunch of people
start to show up these events now this
wasn't until pretty recently and we've
been doing this for seven years and
Griffin I know you've you've had some
years you when you you said you bought
your your house here in in Nashville and
one year you slept there 19 nights in a
year and so you're on the road a lie yes
that's pithy a man a few words this is
minimalism yeah I've spent a lot of time
on the road and I still have I choked
and lycée but maybe not so much a joke
that I have PTSD from the days where I
would show up driving 12 hours to get to
Tucson Arizona and it wouldn't play I'd
be this third act on and it'd be 11
people there or something and just go
like what the hell am I doing with my
life you know and just feeling like it
took forever and now you know like I we
were talking about before it's it is
okay I interrupt you why did you why did
you feel like because I felt the exact
opposite like I remember when we showed
our very first tour stop st. Petersburg
Florida there were six people who showed
up eight if you count me and Ryan and I
was like oh my god this is what I'm
doing with my life and it never felt to
me like I mean we never ANDed we never
had zero people show up almost and and I
don't know maybe it felt to me like wow
if someone's here to listen then I want
to sort of yeah I don't get this out
there I hadn't told that
stand the grind of driving 12 hours
through Arizona also waking up on a rest
stop and sleeping there the next night
we've done that as well it feels like I
mean people think they see like the
glamour behind especially a musician's
life going out and being a rock star
playing songs in front of crowds of
people but there's the whole other side
that's not glamorous at all right yeah I
think that may be the answer to the
question is that it's exciting to do
something that you believe in and put a
lot of passion and like do a book or you
know a podcast or have a Netflix show or
make a record and when I'm came to
Nashville and made a record it was
amazing that it came out over all over
the US it came out in Europe and Canada
and you you feel like it's really
exciting and you get to go do things
like some of the first tours that I got
to do were opening for people like Bruce
Springsteen's wife and like I met Bruce
Springsteen the first like month I was
doing music I moved the National ethical
[ __ ] this is pretty easy you know you
just make a record next thing you know
you're hanging out with Bruce
Springsteen and so you have those you
have those times I mean just like these
great fantastic things happen you're
playing one of the first shows I played
was like four five thousand people
opening for John Mellencamp and then you
kind of feel like all right like I
arrived and then then and then you're
like back to Tucson Arizona
back to reality five people are here and
there's just so many ups and downs where
it's sort of a check for like why am I
doing this am I doing it for the right
reason and I think you know actions kind
of speak tell the truth and I've just
like kind of kept going for whatever
reason because it's what I do is what I
love doing and the point behind saying
that too is is just really how
appreciative it's made me when I go to a
town where there are a hundred people or
200 people or 300 people when I see
people they're after how I know it can
go and how much hard work it's taken
it's it's gratifying you know so it
fills me with a lot of gratitude so
no that's I think it's a great point man
you know we're really stands out to me
is that you you were doing something
that you knew was meaningful and I I'm
curious to see if you feel this way so
we are raised in the in the Western
world especially with the idea that if
you find something you love to do you
never work a day in your life how do you
feel about that
I'm just curious on I mean I've this
isn't a gotcha question I'm just no I
grew up with a really hard-working I
don't know if you can call it Midwestern
work ethic but just hard-working family
lots of farmers around where I come from
just you just sort of like get up work
hard and go about it and so that came
with what I do and I enjoy I can't
really do it any other way I feel good
when I worked that way and I don't know
I just it's never I've never had an on
willingness to do that and when I find
myself at home where I'm not staying
busy I sort of I kind of maybe that's a
bad thing but I'm these days is sort of
like how do I find a balance between
taking care of myself and not having to
be some sort of a workaholic but just
really have a balance in my life so what
am i hearing you say is you've work
really arts though yeah and you do love
what you do I do and you know I love
what I do and it's you know I personally
I think that that is a unreasonable
expectation I think that there are
there's someone out there who certainly
wakes up every day and they're like oh
man I'm so happy that's great but for
every single person to expect that it's
it's I just like I said I think it's an
unreasonable expectation because Josh
and I we love what we do but we work
really really hard so I'll say the first
thing to the business model is work
really hard and I know that's like
really simple but again that's what we
do or the minimalist but no work really
hard and when it ever becomes we're at
when it ever comes to a point where you
feel like you shouldn't be doing like if
you honestly you're questioning to
yourself like man am I in this for the
right reason
maybe I'm not this is affecting my
relationships or it's affecting
my house like that's when you want to
look at it and say okay like maybe this
isn't for me but as long as it's
aligning with your values and beliefs
and you're working super hard at it I
mean that whatever you're doing is going
to turn into something successful now
the level of success I don't know I mean
does that mean you're gonna be a
millionaire you're probably not but will
you be able to pay the bills like that's
that's what I thought when Josh and I
when we went on that first tour it
wasn't about like oh man how can I
replace you know this this salary with
another big salary I mean it was it was
about like how can I live a life that
aligns with my values and beliefs and it
started with the tour and I thought
eventually I'd have to get a job as a
barista to kind of help supplement my
income the reason being is because that
would still allow me to write and would
still give me flexible hours and a
part-time barista job to do the things
that I loved you hit the nail on the
head man it is adding value if I had to
add to that I would say find the biggest
need right now with your audience
and fill that need because here's the
thing like when Josh and I we didn't
charge for anything for that first year
it was all essays we were writing we
were just you know we had some really
cool ideas cool conversations and we
were able to put him in words and put
them up on the website as soon as you
know as soon as we you know launched
Josh's writing class my mentoring
services when we when we published our
first book it was not it wasn't you know
this this flood of sales but what it was
it was enough for Josh and I to pay our
bills that first year I think I was
looking like my Social Security
Statement
it was like $23,000 I made that year but
I traveled more that year than I had
ever traveled I had more fun that year
just you know going out and meeting
people and to me it was never about
again about having a big salary it was
about doing something that I loved that
was meaningful work and that would allow
me to still pay the bills if you're on
that track right now I mean really keep
going dude that's that's what you got to
do because you know when I look at
someone like you you got two kids and a
white you got a family to take care of
you know now you've got a kid in the
family like if if something if [ __ ] was
to hit the
with the minimalists or with you know
Griffin's music like I know he's got a
good work ethic and he's gonna find
something else that he loves to do and
he's gonna work super hard at it and
again that will get to a a certain level
of success what level that is I don't
know but keep doing what you're doing
man you're gonna be fun here's here's a
pithy answer for you
if you're just getting started say yes
till you have to say no and then say no
until you have to say yes thank you all
right you a quick interruption if you
want to listen to our bonus episode this
week as well as all of our past bonus
episodes head on over to the minimalists
dot-com and click donate at the top of
our website each week we publish the
minimalists private podcast exclusively
for our patreon supporters this private
podcast shows up in your normal podcast
feed like Apple podcasts overcast Google
Play or whatever podcast app you use and
it shows up right next to our normal
weekly podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast and film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated alright
y'all back to the regular show actually
you know what we'll go back to the
regular podcast but I want to add one
other thing to what you were just saying
there about the the 24 hours so on the
podcast we're at the private podcast
we're just recording the 24 hour news
cycle you're talking about how
everything is breaking news now right
and I think our mine is has a really
hard time discerning but
like whatever that the top headline is
so you get a newspaper like it's
whatever's above the fold is there's a
27 people shot in Sutherland Springs
Texas right we were we were just down in
Houston when that happened and that's
the main thing on the headline of the
paper and then the next day it's like
Kim kardashian-west gets into a fight
with with Kanye and that's also above
the fold and you're like well wait a
minute like all of a sudden our mind
treats that the same exact way and we if
we don't pay attention to what we're
letting in then it all becomes an
emergency and back to what Griffin was
talking about there when we start focus
on everyone else's problems
it might make our problems seem seem
less significant and and then we don't
work on fixing those problems at all
because we're always worried about the
problems in the world and if we don't
look inward then that's a problem the
other word you used was propaganda and
man we were just over at Beck's and I we
went over to the frist Museum and I saw
that exhibit in Tulsa the one you're
talking the World War one yeah yeah
there's this World War one exhibit over
there and they're all these propaganda
posters and I mean some of them are
quite dated like there's this one where
it's this woman who's like dressed like
scantily clad in a navy uniform and it's
like I wish I was a man so I could join
the Navy and you just imagine like there
were some guys who are like wow she'd
probably think I was attractive if I
went and died from this cause I don't
know anything about and then it's really
about okay I need to stay I need to stay
in form is this the right decision not
just let this propaganda make the
decision for me and so keep that in mind
whenever you're seeing an advertisement
it is propaganda there are their
advertisers there are demographers there
are a lot of people who went to Ivy
League schools to try to divorce you
from your bank account
and they do a really good job at a wheat
we every year we spend 1.2 billion
dollars on non-essential goods that's
that's stuff we don't need
by the way we spent 200 so that's 1.2
trillion we spend 200 million or 200
billion sorry on on charitable giving so
we spend a trillion less on giving to
people who need it then on buying stuff
that we don't need and and so it's just
something to think about
Griffin I want to thank you for being
here with us tonight man I'm such an
honor to be here with you guys tonight
thank you thank you very much very much
think if you all live here tonight with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works Thank You Nashville
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is Adrian and I'm from
Raleigh North Carolina and this message
is in response to the happier podcast
that just aired you guys were talking
about meditation and how it could
possibly lead you to a dark place if you
have never done that before and you
spent like maybe a long time and
meditation and I just have a lot of
insight into that I just wanted to share
that yes it could bring yourself to a
dark place however for me personally I
was able to uncover a lot of traumatic
events that I've suppressed since
childhood through meditation and
although that led me to a very dark
place
initially it led me to where I am now
which is a much happier version of
myself so I just wanted to share that
for listeners who may be turned off by
that idea I think that it is worth it so
to meditate Thank You laughter my name
is Joseph Joseph sumac and I live in
Clifton New Mexico which you'll have a
hard time finding on the map because
it's the boondocks but at any rate I've
been listening to your podcast for a
while now I'm fascinated by your what
you're doing minimalism is the first ISM
I felt drawn to in recent memory I've
listened to a number of podcasts I must
say I'm quite impressed if your
articulation of something I felt for
most of my life starting in my teens I
came to a point of critical awareness
that would be 40 years ago when I
dropped out of college to reconsider my
options for me the decision was a
visceral one initially resulting from my
low tolerance for emotional and
psychological stress I moved out to a
place where I could squat rent-free for
a while on the mountains of New Mexico I
loved it I paid off student loans of a
few thousand with a part-time job in a
couple years living without a car and by
depending on my bicycle I managed quite
well
during my life in general except for a
certain degree of isolation I've always
been that adverse and aside from the
above and the occasional medical debt
I've avoided indentured servitude
I developed a unique style of living
where I would work for a period of time
save money then quit to play for a while
I loved having free time spend most of
my free time in nature backpacking which
is an excellent way to practice
minimalism by limiting my material least
needs to what I can carry on my back as
I have aged I've become more interested
in community and decided 20-some years
ago to find or create a community where
I could retire without a great deal of
wealth too but for me I was recently
listening to financial podcast and
thought I would share my approach as an
alternative at least it has been a very
challenging but rewarding process that
has led to my current situation which is
living in a rural intentional community
so my retirement plan is a unique blend
of developing relationships of mutual
support in this community that I live in
combine developing skill sets like
herbalism gardening plumbing carpentry
that work well with that in a remote
rural economy of exchange hey guys I'm
Lou and I'm calling from Atlanta Georgia
last month my home was robbed and as a
single mom living with only my young son
it's been really crazy dealing with the
emotions around feeling so totally
violated and having my possession stolen
I found your podcast actually around the
same time as the robbery and listening
to it has been such a huge comfort for
me understanding that the items that
were stolen some replaceable some
completely irreplaceable like the family
jewelry my grandma passed down to me
understanding that those are just items
they're just things the person who
entered my home and took my things
can't take the memory that I have of the
look of joy on my grandmother
space when she gave me her jewelry what
really matters to me
can't be stolen for me and miss silver
lining is that now I have less stuff can
I use the stolen items towards your
30-day minimalism game oh I think it's
still too soon to make jokes but I just
wanted to thank you for the podcast and
the work that you do
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you gotta grab oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
team
[Music]
you